バッハ
はっはっは
た
おっ
桃米ちゃん花火社長ですはいてあげて今回アマゾンでとまるで amazon かなあ
まぞんじゃねーぞ
これ箱 amazon なんですけどアマゾンから取り寄せるわけではありません今月
の特殊なこの買いましたでコナン前からちょっと今回はあの開封の前はできないです
申し訳なく粉がとベゼルといえば危険なのでやっぱねこう言うかなものというなれば
安全に安全3
あーそろそろ心配になってきましたもう普通に開けますあぁ手が空いてるし
きたきたきたきたレブちょっとちょっとでちゃった目ちょっとでちゃったじゃーん
分かってたけどね奉納品紹介て植えて今
買い替えましたのはポリアクリル酸ナトリウムを5キロぐらいわかりましたポリ
アクリル酸ナトリウムどんなものかといいますとちょっと見てみましょううわなんか
ちょっとこんな競ってねー何っていうのは神たくない添加物だからちょっとあんまり
よろしくないと思うときますよね
愛というポリアクリーさんなぞりうちも土産袋を買いました合計1kg
まずこれが良いものか悪いのか持つという鉱山ねちょっと気調べて皆さん堀100 b
さんがという
水分吸収率の高さを良性と米つとかローソンとか
へっ
減ったことにあと蓄冷剤芳香剤食品添加物などにも利用されておりますすごいね色んな
ことに使われてるみたいで超でキチン稼働ができちゃうたら危険性危険性あるよか
トヨタ
毒性は長軸位らしいです山地味なマネしないでねああよかったそんなに姉に危ないけど
ね食品添加物だから多少なりとも毒性の患者があると思うんですけどもすごい9
sed to do んですけど
水をかけるとターン席が何十倍には不クラブコーナーらしいです水を吸うプロパティみ
ましょうピューどぅっひとまずこんなぐらいにしトッポすっごい呼吸性豊かさが魅力だ
ねこれがどうパケですね
ちょっと水を入れてみます俺も全然わからないんだけど
ちょっと少なかったのかなあれどうだはぁっ
あっ
それでチャイあれ俺どこれやすくリサーナ取りうって聞いたんだけどバネに何かもっと
さを破って盛り上がる予定だったんですけどもうちょっと水入れてみましたちょっと
思ってたんだけど違うよもっとザバーってなかったん
恋
あ
ねえあれなんかさ違うんで俺の中でもう水を入れた散歩にもヨレヨレもりってなかった
んだけど何空さで言ってるアーマーこれデンジャーもってわけわかんない背中スライム
みたいになってます何か違うなこれでお前以外で魂本能から全然違うなんでなんでなん
ておかしおかしおかしてとりあえずは今まで分かったと思うんですけどあれだけにずれ
ても水
はポイント来なくなりますむしろ行う落ちていきますので吸水性はめちゃくちゃもっと
水を入れた方がいいのかもですねもうちょっと水入れてみますきっとさあや
多分水が少なかったんだよ
脳もいやモード羽に行くやお茶をがっつり入れました
あのガッツに卒業いっ
おっ
なんでなんでなんですよ
をは違うちょっと待ってよ
ちょっと待ってよもう寒天ゼリーじゃないですか
あっ茶髪熱々めっちゃ発熱してるんで僕は36度5分で何度ぐらいなんてこと絶対や汁
はいやいやはぁ今計ってみたんですけど40度キューブです完全に e フレンズもう
何かあっあーっなんだろうねまーすっ
水を吸収してるのはわかるんですけど6の異名ちょっと水を吸水するね花が水を吸収し
て膨張しますそしてこのひとつ粒ずつ大きくなってこう
こんな時代が暴釣イメージだったんですけども今回完全に凝固しに行きましたいやー
これはちょっと実験でしたねなんでだろ a
なって1キロを買ったんですけどなぜもんなんか無駄に使う必要ないでしょなんで
だろーなーわかんないや秋水ポリマーというものは難しい
私ず理科の勉強になったんじゃないですかねまだちょっと特殊な物質を見つけたらまた
捕まえてみようと思いますご覧さんとあいさつしを見てくれた皆に挨拶はみんな
ありがとう
よかった8月あのねちゃんと水からスクラムんだよ
資料お気を付け
ます no 9できましたようせいのふえました the また次の動画でお会いし
ましょうじゃあな
nerf
いいえいます
プっています